my name is Luca Petrovich and I'm with
learner 43 sports
I actually never had like goals of
actually going pro I said like cause of
living the normal life or just going to
school you know playing game for fun
started watching some LCS and it was
just like fun to watch these games and
dispro players and then I climbed in
soloqueue and then at one point when I
joined the g2 200 team and it was again
another one I didn't wanna go through I
just wanted to get some money you know
it was like my school my school summer
break and I was like oh free money
if I'm good like amazing is exhausted
down trick comes in for some relief
pitching the fish is on hi Bridget and
Sean and now first kids a killing spree
to pick up amazing flips for power
return that's a double kill for the fish
my parents Nuala that was really good at
the game and and I found the way to
basically do exams in the offseason so
they find out companies
so the qualified with lineup hybrid
Jesse Smitty and kikis jungle so that
was like pretty special line of no
season should be made some water changes
some people didn't really like to play
each other and it was miracle that he
won in relegations we didn't even know
the lineup for a long time but you know
if he was gonna stay jungle or even if
it was up my own name was like dope or
some Dino yeah I guess we exceeded over
all those expectations I didn't really
get affected by peoples opinions like on
reddit or whatever bottom si or my
performance teams from as an aside
because I knew what how I felt and power
plates and after MSI I guess I wanted to
like to people again everyone was like
they're stalking us like oh this is
gonna be [ __ ] adjudication lava and now
we are first again mister tornado it'll
be very hard to get you to play here
Coffeyville hooks are shutting off my
Raviv on mid lane he's gonna flash away
but the Ignite will take him down for
the first blood over to part the
complete method change and members
changed soros a change may display a be
different in the beginning and meta
wasn't like million centric so I like
hard time I was not really hard time but
took me some time to realize how the map
is different and how I should play a lot
more safe and smarter
I would like to play SKT and RNG because
I think at MSI he got stomped by a
scripted ball games but by vs. RNG we
were both games I had and they could
have easily one more system actually
just wanted in vs. aren t I want to
revenge versus rng so i just want to
play the best koreans and chinese teams
and I would like to face the assign
action TSM is like so good in na and
they're very good players and very good
Molina so looking forward to play those
things the return kill but in the end
he's still going to drop in perks the
triple kill the Quadra kill coming in
this man 1 b5 the dream for the vladimir
I know we are completely different team
we play on the straight like macro game
and we really don't go for coolest thing
fighting like we did before so that's
what I guess I learned from my first
pitch is that coolest aggression is not
good that's why I got punished for it
even the finals I know them for very
long time I have known their
personalities and I knew how good of the
players ever like we trust each other
and all can always say like criticism or
I don't think the champ is good or maybe
it is strong and bla bla now everything
is like going by the plan we are
improving so much playing a complete
objective game and there is barely any
like stupid mistakes so Jude is gonna be
involved so we're gonna make up for it